Pro Football Hall of Famer Howie long
how are you how he I'm good Ritz a
little tired but good excited I I I'm
sure you are I please put into words
best you can about what what it's this
last two-year run has been like watching
Chris do what they're done
Howie well I you know Richard really
what what came to mind last night as I
was watching the game unfold and then
you know of course the kind of game
dynamic was totally different than the
Super Bowl last year you know being down
what I think twenty eight two three year
and at that point thinking I was the
worst dad in the world for recommending
that he go to New England so like I can
help him with his chemistry you know
right
any of his homework but I could
certainly tell you which way to go and
football but at that point it didn't
look good but you know III saw the
confusion pre-snap
on Minnesota's first touchdown and went
oh no you know easy touchdown take it
down the field go the big play on the
interception would seem to you know go
forever and that place just erupted it
was it was remarkable and and as the
game the clock was winding down and Kyle
was down on the field and Diane Chris's
mom was down on the field and Megan and
Whelan her grandson I was thinking back
to all those Sunday nights you know
where you're you're trying to find a way
to you know give your son a pep talk
after another loss in st. Louis for
eight years you know and and it was rich
I ran out of things to you know I was on
whatever Instagram trying to find you
know inspirational quotes I ran out of
Knute Rockne stuff Lombardi you name it
I kind of ran out of it and it's only
fitting that you know you'd like to
think that good things happen to good
people and as you and I both know that's
not always the case but you keep hoping
and chris is an extraordinary example of
someone who always does the right thing
is someone who poured his heart and soul
into his eight years in st. Louis and
was you know a great teammate and a
really great player there and had some
injuries at the end gets released and
ends up with New England and one wins a
Super Ball now on to Philadelphia place
where Dinah and I both went to school
and have a lot of friends and and
knowing that Philadelphia area and the
kind of fans they have which it's you
know each fanbase is unique in Philly's
really unique and and it's just so
exciting well I mean during during your
your comments right there Howie we were
showing on on screen on our television
portion of the simulcast just the
pictures of your beautiful grandson on
your back he is rich he is the grandson
thing rich I have to tell you I I didn't
think you know you always hear and
listen I don't love my grandson any more
than I love my sons but you don't have
any of that father-son angst back when
it's it's just pure unadulterated love
and and it's just so special and he saw
me on the stage and ran over there and
Megan pulled him up to me and he want to
sit on my lap and you know he was just
happy as a clam and you know I read one
article today where some writer ripped
me for you know nothing impartial enough
well rip away oh well look I mean let me
tell you something when your son's
playing in the NFC Championship game and
you're gonna be impartial in that route
form I mean hey listen I have a great
deal of respect for Minnesota
great deal anyone who's ever heard me
all year long including
last week running up to the game I
remember watching Minnesota on countless
occasions on film when Chicago is
getting ready to play them and I'm
looking at this defense on saying how do
pre-snap how do you figure this out
there there are really really
well-constructed team and I told their
GM that yesterday I said you guys look
great getting off the bus man it's
they're there and they're gonna be good
for a long time
so I had a lot of respect for them and I
knew the task was it was really a
difficult one and Nick you know who's
heart rate I don't think ever gets above
62 Nick Foles and and a head coach who
talked about aggressive play calling
yeah you know I well look Howie I mean
here's this thing I mean if anybody
knows you for even a split second they
know that you respect the game okay they
know what it likes to be what it means
to play this game and play it at a high
level and respect opponents and you know
if you're bouncing your grandson on your
lap I mean forget about wouldn't do
something like that Howie I mean come on
now people need to get over themselves
true well then let's let's move on to
this point about our son because and and
look I'm biased too because I've known
you for a long time and I've known your
son too and Chris and you and your and
your whole family
so having Chris on a stage like the
Super Bowl for the next two weeks is to
me for somebody who covers the sport and
wants it to succeed in every way
possible it's monumental because I know
he's gonna use this platform for the
right reasons which is obviously not to
just win the game but it is to talk
about other issues as a matter of fact
he I don't know if you saw it on social
media at all he retweeted the NFL shop
that tweeted out a t-shirt of the dog
masks saying hey you know go get your
t-shirts here he retweeted that saying
are you gonna donate the funds like you
should essentially what's you know rich
that's the thing you know I it's one
thing to
talk the talk but to walk the walk and I
mean really walk the walk I mean where
you take nothing he he just gives and
gives and gives
it's when did you first learn that he
was going to do that Oh was an old soul
young age and I remember one night
because you know that I I'm a late
worker I work late I'm not an early
person when I'm a late person I watched
film late and it was third year maybe at
in st. Louis and he called me at about
God had to be 12:30 1:00 in the morning
uh-huh and he you know he just wanted
his life to have purpose and wanted it
to be impactful and you know beyond you
know the football and playing in the NFL
he just wanted to do something he just
kind of felt like he wasn't contributing
enough and you know although in college
he was big brothers and you know he had
a he was a big brother to a challenge
it's been and did countless things there
at the University of Virginia and which
was doing things you know with what he
called Joel's heroes in st. Louis at the
time where he'd bring 20 25 30
inner-city kids to a game every week and
you know I'm thinking myself well what
24 year old is you know he's the only
guy no I think it's 15 he had a bucket
list I mean who does that rich you know
and and I've said this many times you
know you you as parents we try to teach
and you you're you and your wife for
doing the same thing and you know every
parent out there is trying to do that in
you you try to live a life that you know
your your kids will hopefully respect
and want to emulate and if you're really
really fortunate and God we're fortunate
you know it comes full circle and your
son ends up teaching inspiring you
it's pretty remarkable and so when he
calls you say dad I'm gonna end up
donating my entire salary we're too rich
you know I mean I made 38 grand my
rookie year my check was an after-tax I
drove over used Coupe de Ville it was in
Oakland California and I was on top of
the world and my check after taxes was a
little just a skosh over $1,000 but he's
been very fortunate to play in a in a
time when players are being compensated
the way they should be become the sated
and he's someone who's always been
mindful of taking care of his money so
he's fortunate to be in a position to do
that and and to do those kinds of things
and Kyle is also very supportive and has
built a well himself Terry Bradshaw you
know one day just on the set you know
what I'm gonna build me one of those
wells
I'll take 145 grand you know I mean he
inspires the people around them and he's
so genuine he's someone that you know
not just from a football standpoint you
want on your football team but he
challenges everyone to raise the level
of all aspects of their lives
yeah you're talking about water boys
again water boys org to learn more on
that
Howie before I let you go apropos of
none of what we've just discussed in our
number three of my show I have the actor
Dolph Lundgren coming into studio so we
decided look love there the big rematch
with his son oh that's right Brad so we
wanted to bring up you read our poll
question of the day to Howie Long Chris
Brown yeah here's our poll question
today who's got the best action movie
flat top you Dolph longeron are we added
Val Kilmer also what do you think Howie
I'm trying to think of when did valve
uh-oh
I got you and that goes way back I I
just saw him in a kind of an offbeat the
the Snowman
miss murder mystery movies with Dolph
Lundgren and he was kind of okay
they had him all made up to the point
where you couldn't recognize him I don't
think but you know hey listen rocky are
you kidding me okay you know going to
fightin the training in Siberia and the
shack and you know he's breaking all the
machines and yeah III wrote an elevator
with him once seems like a really sharp
guys smart guy chemical engineer am I
too long before a Good Will Hunting you
know so yeah okay so you give him you're
gonna give him the flattop and yeah and
plus it was about two three inches
higher than mine okay okay you're
winning was high and was low and tight
okay yeah you're winning the pole right
you're winning right now Howie's yeah
well that's very nice of the folks out
there but you know dolphins okay
no look hey long families on a roll
Holly you know NFC championship team two
Super Bowls in a row for Chris and how
he longs got winning the Rich Eisen
jacket that's warm exactly okay look I
look forward to seeing you and your
family out of there or to a partner okay
thanks again for the call Football Hall
of Famer the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience